I've talked to a number of my friends
that have retired in the last four or
five years and the thing that they all
say is they have yet to find something
that fills the competitive void you know
I actually draw a comparison between
what you described being on the trail
yeah that's probably the closest I'll
ever get to an NBA game and though I
have been courtside so you know there's
that but certainly I can see people who
in politics also chase that high again
[Music]
right very happy to welcome to yang
speaks or appear on his podcast
depending upon where you're listening
this the 15th most prolific three-point
shooter in NBA history mr. JJ Redick
JJ welcome Andrew thanks for having me
on I'm actually I'm actually tied for
14th with LeBron yeah that's true you're
tied for 14th no I'm just kidding I'm
only kidding no I'm excited to hopefully
play some basketball I don't think
anyone expected us to be potentially
playing games under these circumstances
so it should be a little little weird
well for you I feel like for you'd be a
bit of a homecoming because you started
your career in Orlando so it's going to
be like going back to familiar haunts
though I guess it's not in the arena
yeah it's over across the way and in
Disney World you were saying that this
reminds you of AAU is that right yeah
yeah I mean so starting in eighth grade
and then ninth grade 10th grade 11th
grade each summer after those grades you
would go down to Orlando for like two
three weeks and just you'd stay at a
hotel and like Kissimmee and you'd
shuttle back and forth between Disney
World Wide World of Sports and you'd
play you know two or three games
a day for four weeks at a time the
difference now is that we can't leave
the property so we're we're like
quarantined in one place for potentially
you know three months but it'll be very
similar the interesting thing is the
league is now saying that if you're not
playing in a game you know you can go
watch other teams play in person because
there's gonna be no fans in the crowd so
we're all sort of in the same bubble so
I'm I'm actually interested to see how
no fans plays out and how other guys
going to games play out and if they
start heckling you know friends on their
team or maybe guys they don't like on
the other team because there's not going
to be any and any other noise fan noise
- filters they can hear you it's true
you shout some yeah so what
proportion of NBA players do you think
played in those AAU games probably most
of the domestic is that right I would
assume so I think a lot of guys in my
generation certainly played in that AAU
tournament down in Orlando so it's going
to feel familiar to just about everyone
in a different way
at least that came of age in the same
way now for you you're a family man at
this point you've got young kids and
does the family go with you is that is
that the plan or how does that work well
the NBA has said in the in the NBA our
union agreed to allow families to come
into the bubble once the first round of
the playoffs are done so most teams will
arrive sometime between July 7th and 9th
and the first round of the playoffs will
be done probably around the end of
August so you're looking at around 2
months if you make it that far with no
family but for most players that you
know don't live in the same place that
they play like myself I live in Brooklyn
I'm playing in New Orleans you know I've
got a quarantine down in New Orleans so
my family's not coming with me so I
actually will be without my family for
for at least 2 months because I'm headed
down to New Orleans momentarily yeah
that's
really difficult man I mean how old are
your kids they're gonna be six and four
in August so if we make the playoffs I
won't be there for their birthdays yeah
I mean having two young kids myself two
months consecutively away from them is a
long time like I was traveling on the
road for the campaign but even in my
case most like one to two week periods
I'd be able to sneak back home for like
a day or two like if you go ten days in
a row not seeing your family that's
actually a long time we got young kids
so for you two months that must be much
longer than you'd be used to is that
right for sure
and it's interesting you bring up the
point about trying to sneak back home
for a day because there's periods of
time during the season or during our
marriage where you know Chelsea maybe
was in New York for an extended period
of time I was still playing in LA and we
would have these two to three day gaps
and I would actually fly LA to New York
to go back home or in the case of New
Orleans like she went up for Christmas
break and stayed through Christmas with
the kids I was on a West Coast trip I
happen to be up here like two days after
they came up here playing Philly so I
drove up after the game and then flew
back to New Orleans the next day just to
see the kids for a night literally an
hour that time literally our dude
literally know where it would be like I
would take the red-eye back from
California like you know be like
fundraising or campaigning out there and
then take the red-eye show up surprise
the kids for like a couple hours and
then like you know hop on a plane to I
or whatever what's what's the longest
you've gone do you know like the longest
you've gone without seeing your kids
during the heyday of the campaign it
stretched onto maybe let's call it two
weeks like between two and three weeks
where I would just not have any exposure
to my family and that was really hard
you know like down the stretch the
family actually came to me when we had a
campaign bus and the rest of it and then
I got dad cool points like it was the
first time my kids actually thought like
my running for president was cool it was
like there's a bus with dad's head on it
but so yeah I but I was like you where I
would
spend eight hours traveling to get like
two or three hours with the family and
then hit the road again about 15 days I
think around that level this will this
will absolutely absolutely be the
longest period of time that I will have
gone without seeing the kids obviously
for my wife I went the first 22 years of
my life without seeing her so I should
be fine in that regard well one of the
things that happened to me JJ is like so
and this is something this will just be
general relationship or marriage advice
or whatever but one thing that that goes
wrong is when you and your partner are
focused on different things and then you
talk to each other in like there's like
a bit of a barrier between you and at
least in my family's case it's like my
wife's like laser-focused my kids and
then I'd be laser-focused on let's call
it work or the campaign and then it's
like harder to communicate with your
partner and I think like at least for me
Evelyn's naturally just focus on the
kids so like the more you could share
then the more you guys like sync sync up
and click so the fact that you're not
gonna see your kids for X period of time
I mean like it sounds like Chelsea would
be like I'm not gonna miss JJ but
Chelsea starts to like it's nice to eat
at her yeah the kids don't see you at
least that's the way it happens in my
house well it's interesting because I
feel like the dynamics of you know a lot
of relationships are that way where
where there's one person who has to
sacrifice a little bit and be
laser-focused on the house and
truthfully in a way like I have the
luxury of being laser focused on sort of
the big picture of things and and
Chelsea said that to me other day you
know you you always think about the big
things the big things the big things I
need help on the details ie
you know making the shirt sure the kids
change out the pajamas in the morning
and can you do the dishes and doing all
those sorts of things which I naturally
do but look we can all sort of help out
our partner a little bit more so it's
that's been one of the interesting
things just about this whole experience
in in kovat is I mean I've never I've
never lived just objectively exactly
No
so it's it's been it's been interesting
it's been it's been an experience for
sure well I'll say for me I've gotten to
know my kids better because I was on the
trail last two years you know you'd have
like a day here a day there and then
spending weeks consecutively with them
like you know I actually just literally
know my children better than I did at
any point in the past and you know and
also my kids your kids are about the
same age they're actually like
developing more personality and
awareness where you can interact with
them in different ways than was the case
when they were younger so I'm sure you
had the same experience I mean it's one
of the things you don't like to you know
go into it but like at least for me that
was sort of a blessing honestly of this
time oh no doubt and and my youngest who
will be four like I said in August is
really starting to develop his
personality where you know when we moved
to New Orleans and and my family came
with me to New Orleans so when we moved
in October you know he was he was a
certain way and now he's just a
completely different kid yeah it's it's
and he's like we used to call him
Squishy cuz he was a little bit chubby
so actually knocks my oldest named him
squishy when he was a baby because he
was a very chubby baby but he's now like
thinned out and he's got muscles and
he's he's so talking it just it's fun
for any parent you know it's it's really
fun to see your kids obviously grow
physically but seeing their
personalities develop is is one of like
the most rewarding things in life for
sure yeah I couldn't agree more man you
know remember when you signed with New
Orleans
I remember scratching my chin for a
minute being like huh
because you know I'd be like you had
this awesome career I think you might
have like the longest streak of
consecutive playoffs made or something
like that in the NBA right now what is
it like love years 13 years longest
active playoff streak yeah 13 years in a
row yeah and you're clearly in demand
like your core skill is now the most
important skill in the NBA arguably
you played on these contending teams and
showed that you can help anyone win at
the highest levels and so I remember
when you signed with New Orleans like I
personally as a fan was like you know
like scratching my chin being like huh
like that that's sort of an interesting
choice for for JJ can can you and you
probably talked about this in other
context but like was a lot of that let
you know driven by at that point had
they already gotten the number one pick
and you knew it was gonna be Zion
because if here there's a Duke
connection or is there something else
that drove you to New Orleans sure I had
finished my second year in Philly we
lost to the Toronto Raptors in a
heartbreaking fashion Kawhi Leonard hits
a buzzer beater in Game seven of the
Eastern Conference semifinals to beat us
there's that sort of licking the wound
period that every athlete goes through
when your season ends without a
championship so there's two weeks that
go by and you know then all of a sudden
it was like well we're a month away from
free agency and so you start having
conversations with your agent and you
know people around the league to try to
get get a sense of what the landscape is
going to be you know the issue for me
was I I did want to go back to Philly we
had sort of established a life in
Brooklyn I was commuting to and from
Philly everyday you know it was not an
easy commute but I was doing it my
family was really settled here in
Brooklyn my sister or my wife's twin
sister lives three blocks from us here
in Brooklyn so we just felt like this
was really our home the opportunity with
New Orleans I looked at in a number of
ways
first of all financially it was the most
lucrative contract that was offered to
me last summer but Trajan Langdon had
just been hired as a GM David Griffin
had just been hired as the president of
basketball operations vice president all
intents and purposes he's the president
they get the number one pick about three
or four days before a free agency they
draft Zion they draft Jackson Hays with
the 8th pick they draft Nikhil Alexander
Walker with the 17th pick they make the
trade they trade Anthony Davis they
bring in Lonzo ball they bring in
Brandon Ingram and there was a number of
days where like you're waiting like I
wonder if Philly's going to work
I wonder if Philly's gonna work out and
I just felt like if if if all this great
stuff is happening in New Orleans like I
I can move my family for a year too and
and this will be a great opportunity as
well it also offered me another another
chance to mentor younger players and to
sort of be the voice of reason in the
locker room and to to help guys
obviously grows players but but but grow
as men in this league and and that's
been something that I got to do in in
Philly and that I've continued in New
Orleans and that's been hugely rewarding
for me that's awesome I'm sure that's
one reason why Trajan and David wanted
you so badly because they had they knew
they'd have a bunch of youngsters and
then they were gonna bring you in as
like the ultra disciplined vet helped
help steer them straight
[Music]
you know I know question as a fan I'd
love your perspective on so you come
into the league thirteen years ago you
know you have this really storied
college career but it's not like you're
a slam dunk sure thing you don't get
like tons of playing time earlier in
your career it's a different league than
to where you know wasn't as shooting
focused and so my big question is you've
now played with the kinds of different
dudes across the career my big question
is like how much of NBA player success
is predicated on just like getting a
little bit lucky in terms of having like
a coaching staff that believes in you or
like the right development around you
like how many guys come into the league
where you know clearly they actually had
the right talent level or makeup to
succeed but it didn't work out for
whatever reason like how much of us just
frickin dumb luck arbitrary and how much
of it is you know because to me they're
all of these guys where you think
yourself like that person should have
succeeded somewhere but they ended up in
like a bad situation once twice and then
that's it because you know the NBA is
not exactly like oh like let's give this
person another chance kind of
environment it's like everyone just
tried to win win win so how how much of
the success is based upon your getting
like the right opportunities and are
there a few guys that you played with
where you were like that person actually
should still be in the NBA but is not
because they just had a little bit a bit
of like bad luck or bad organization fit
sure it's a great question first of all
and I think you could apply this to a
lot of different industries a lot of
different professions yes so there's
there's five to ten percent of NBA
players where luck situation teammates
system it doesn't really matter they're
just that much better than everyone else
whether it's physical or skill they're
just that much better and those guys I
believe could thrive on any team in any
system with any coach
then there's a there's a there's a
separate group of guys who you know call
it like 80% of the leader 70% of the
league that you know they're good enough
they care enough about the game and they
they're smart enough that their can
figure out and adapt coach to coach team
to team season to season and then the
rest of the league is that you know 15
to 20 percent of guys who my math might
have been off there but but the last
group there where they're they're
they're fringe guys or they it is it is
relevant to their situation and and who
the coach is and who's around them and
what their role is I I would always say
this in any of those whether it's the
five to ten maybe not the five to ten
percent but let's say the other 90% of
the league here's what matters most they
have to care enough about basketball and
love basketball enough to work through a
lot of ups and downs to work through the
grind to work through self-doubt and all
the mental hurdles that this game
provides us they have to be they have to
be smart enough to figure all that stuff
out on the fly in real time with
immediate feedback and they also they
also have to be sort of this is another
part of it they have to be smart enough
to operate you know emotionally
intelligent enough to operate inside a
locker room if you're one of the five or
10% of the best guys you can kind of
afford to be an if you're in
that next tier it's hit or miss if
you're that last tier you can't be an
you gotta be like everyone's
favorite dude you're at Italy cuz your
talent your talent is not worth you know
the headache that you're bringing into a
locker room and look the guys who have
figured that that dynamic out maybe
aren't as skilled or as talented as some
of the other guys I've played with but
they've had ten eleven twelve thirteen
year careers because they figured that
out to answer the last part of your
question there's a guy that I
with we were in the same high school
class we were on the same McDonald's
all-american team we played in the ACC
together he left after his junior year I
entered the draft after my senior year
his name's Rashad McCants he went to UNC
yeah my kids he was like supposed to be
yeah he was an unbelievable player I'm
sure I'm sure he probably can still hoop
a little bit but III just I thought you
know when we were sort of at that age
where we were transitioning in the NBA I
thought he was going to be an
unbelievable player in the NBA I don't
know the reasons why he didn't have a
long career but he's one of those guys
that I always think of that you know was
talented enough to have a to have a long
and illustrious NBA career and for
whatever reason it just didn't work out
and and there's cases across the board
but just because I you know I was
friends with Rashad that he's the first
guy I thought of yeah you know Rashad I
think you said something to the effect
that you know like when you get some
kind of negative reputation it whether
it's deserved or not it just kind of
sort of sticks with you and everyone
just buys into it I think I saw an
interview with Rashad about that no I'm
I was curious about this in part because
you know as a fan you look up and you
see that there are guys who just seemed
to me it's like well it's strange how
that person's not in the league and of
course you don't know the players you
don't know the personalities the way
that you do but that you you feel like
there are some folks that you know just
had a couple of bad breaks know the fact
that you're I want to interrupt you real
quick Andrew yeah please because you
brought up you brought up a great point
and I said this to our team early in the
season when we were in the middle of our
13 game losing streak and I brought up
the point about what people say about
you what people write about you your
reputation and how that sticks and all
of us whether we're a public figure an
athlete we're working at Google we're in
a law law firm whatever it may be the
people above you they're they're writing
a book about you and everything gets put
in that book
whether it's consciously or
subconsciously and when it comes time to
then make decisions of
sure pay about your future about your
role what do you refer to you refer to
the book now the book is a metaphor I've
said it's not a physical book yeah
though sometimes it could be a literal
that's not all of us but but so that
everybody is constantly having this book
being written about them and and you
have to be weary of every action that
you do so your body language matters how
you interact with your teammates how you
interact with your coaches what you say
in the media are you on time to thinks
those things all go in the book and they
all add up over six months or six years
or sixteen years it all adds up and one
more thing from a fan's perspective I
love I love hearing this stuff so
there's four hundred and fifty players
roughly in the NBA and there's a lot of
fans out there who say such-and-such
player sucks
a lot of fans would probably say that
upbeat JJ reddick sucks right
in reality all 450 of us could bust
anyone's ass we would just I mean you
don't want to see us in a one-on-one
game I guarantee that so there there's
there's a there's a sort of relative
scale of talent and ability in the NBA
but relative to the to the broader world
we are 450 play it for the 450 best
players in the league with the exception
of guys like Rashad of course and you
could probably think of a few off the
top of your head as well yeah a couple
of the names is popped into my head and
you could you could shoot these down
because they could be totally wrong but
anthony randolph i was like why is that
guy not in the league and that's a good
one that's a good one and then a recent
vintage Jimmer Fredette like I feel like
that dude tore it up in college he tears
it up overseas and then anytime he gets
a cup of coffee at the NBA he's like
gone so you know just random names that
popped in my head from different time
periods but yeah man I mean you guys
like the best players in the world any
of you could bust any like normal
persons you know I think there's I think
there has to be an ability though to
sort of accept not being the man and I'm
not saying that about Rashad or Jim or
or Anthony Randolph because I've never
played with any of those guys in the NBA
but I played with enough guys to know
that if they would they would probably
rather go play overseas and have the
offense run through them and get the
majority of the shots then be the eighth
or ninth guy on an NBA bench it's not
that they can't play in the NBA or won't
you know are not able to play on the NBA
or wouldn't get a job offer I think a
lot of it comes down to just their
happiness on a day to day basis in
playing basketball because again from a
fan's perspective you would probably say
well what does this guy have to complain
about he's in the NBA but if your day to
day enjoyment of your job no matter what
your paycheck is I don't care who you
are your day to day enjoyment of your
job is not what you feel like it should
be then you're gonna consider other
options I think it was Freud talked
about right the key to happiness is the
balance of love work and play well
unfortunately for us you know we get to
play basketball but it's work and and
that's that's the work portion of our
life it's not like going to the to the
pickup you know at the YMCA that's
that's play this is this is real work
and when it doesn't sort of fulfill you
in in a meaningful way
then maybe guys go overseas and and and
find more meaning there
people underestimate that all the time
JJ where they look up and say like well
you know you're getting paid X like suck
it up you should be happy etc and this
translate to politics 100% where I would
see what other candidates were doing and
like people don't know how miserable a
lot of it can be and so you're like oh
you know what are you doing planing
about your you know running for Congress
or Mikey's running for president or in
your case it's like you know you're paid
getting you're a professional athlete
but if it sucks it sucks like you're
still a human being you know like in in
the in the example you're using it's
like if you're used to being a star with
a ball in your hand and then you're like
you know the 12th man on the bench and
you never get up like you know you could
just be like that sucked
like it doesn't really matter what's
like you know I'd love to play
basketball I'm not playing like you know
I'm low man on the totem pole and the
practices that coaches don't value me
like that can suck regardless of what
your stature is in my case it was like
you go you drive for hours in a rental
car away from your family in the winter
in Iowa to the Union Hall and they're
like eight people there and you're like
this sucks
like it's but and so people like you're
also the human beings like you know all
like the human motivation still apply
it's one of the reasons why I think
people love sports so much because like
the lessons and principles apply
everywhere and a lot of the
organizational success you're talking
about like people in business have that
book of course like you know anytime you
start interacting with the org like the
like any impression you make it's
getting logged somewhere and then you
know you're you're either given the job
or not your other given responsibility
or not I mean it's it's interesting you
don't know this about me but I was like
I was brought in by the NBA Players
Association to be like an
entrepreneurship mentor for some of
those like those post players and there
were both current players and former
players who were in this program and I
was just someone who came in for the day
but I've met a bunch of former players
and I have to say that like I saw how
difficult the adjustment was for many of
them like that adjustment and that's
also the human thing it's like you think
to yourself well like you're you were
one of the best basketball players in
the world you're you have millions of
dollars like there must be no problems
you get there and then there are these
people they were like hey I'm like
retired at the age of 37 I don't know
what the to do like now and you
know I have money but I don't have as
much money as everyone seem to think I
have like everyone thinks I have money
coming out of my ears and and then
people are all coming to me with these
opportunities that require money and
like you know who do I trust what
decisions do I make like what am I so
like you know like the human condition
applies to everyone you know it's like
certainly NBA players so I can see
players would make decisions that a fan
might be like why they do in that but
like you know just comes down to whether
you enjoy it for sure I've talked to a
number of my friends that have retired
in the last four or five years and the
thing that they all say is they have yet
to find something that fills the
competitive void that fills the void the
feeling that you get when you're in a
playoff game on the road you win a big
game you come back to the locker room
those first few minutes back in the
locker rooms if you phoria you feel the
sense of accomplishment you feel your
your your nerves your senses are
heightened it's like hi we've been we've
been programmed now for decades to seek
that as athletes we're programmed that's
that's our that's our brain chemistry
operates on finding that feeling and we
stop playing and it's really hard to
replicate that for anyone but it's
really hard to replicate that if you're
37 or 38 years old and you're got to
start something new and you're starting
a lot of times you know sort of at the
bottom yeah it's it's something I saw
multiple times and one other thing that
a former player said to me he said like
one of the the tough parts is that as a
professional athlete you're always like
the model of competence and fortitude
and strength and so when people come to
you with these opportunities you can't
say like I don't understand what the
hell you're talking about
you get like it actually is like a tough
thing for an athlete to say like look
I'm at the bottom of the totem pole when
it comes to understanding like this
business opportunity like this thing and
so like that there's a lot of feigned
feigned knowledge or like where you're
not able to be honest
this is what a former athlete told me
and I heard this and I was like it makes
a lot of sense because you know you're
like at the pinnacle and one thing
that's very hard to go from that to all
of a sudden saying like I don't know
all about what you're talking know
that requires a little bit of humility I
think the other the other component is
we are relevant
we're relevant as athletes it's much
easier and I've heard so many guys say
this I mean have we get retired players
through the Union come speak to our
teams every year so I've heard this now
for 14 years from multiple players you
know if I want to get if I want to get
on the phone and get in contact with
someone let's say a CEO of a Wall Street
bank a CEO of a food startup those
things are relatively easy for me it
might take one phone call it might take
two it might take one email but
generally speaking I can get in contact
with that person I'm not just saying I
I'm saying the active player as a as a
former player which when you have when
you former NBA player as opposed to NBA
player it's much harder and for a lot of
guys especially in the previous
generation they had they waited until
they were done playing to start pursuing
other opportunities in what you've seen
now in our generation of players and and
even amplified even more so with with
the the current guys that are coming up
you know the 18 to 22 crowd is they all
have something else going on they all
have their hands in something else
they're all pursuing other things and
and still finding that balance of
working and loving the game wow that's
interesting I'm glad people are getting
an earlier start you know I actually
draw a comparison between what you
described about the the nerves and the
energy of the playoff game to being on
the trail and I said just now like you
know oh that that side the fact is like
when I was campaigning when I was in the
dead of winter showing up to Iowa and
there were eight people in the Union
Hall or whatever it was actually still
cool and awesome like I said we cause
like the eight people I was like and I
used to tell this joke I was like you
know how many Californians each of you
is worth
I feel like a thousand each so that's
like there are a thousand people at this
room so I'm well good
and I was good because there was nothing
like fighting for you know the the
future of the country and like if there
was one person I thought could help me
like I didn't care how many people
showed up so that now that's probably
the closest I'll ever get to an NBA game
and though I have been courtside so you
know there's that but the then the the
campaign ends and like we're still doing
other things and I'm like excited about
them but certainly I can see people who
in politics also chase that high again
you know like there are some people and
I don't consider myself one of them
happily but there are some people who
just really get somewhat addicted to the
spotlight or like addicted to being as
you say maybe like highly highly
relevant like I'm not really wired that
way I was like not then not very
accustomed to seeking press the way that
I did on the trail but I can I think
those are parallels man and like it's
it's interesting
I can almost conceptualize like this
like XY bar graph where like if you're a
current player your relevance is like
super high and then when you retire like
it starts to drop like it and preceding
year yeah man that's it's spot-on I was
actually gonna bring this up you kind of
just talked about but I was gonna bring
you this up earlier I can't remember
what you had said earlier but in terms
of your motivation and you and I have
spoken a few times on the phone prior to
this so again coming from a casual sort
of you know a friendship but also my
observance of view as a public figure
you know I've always felt like your
motivation for running for president and
for doing the things that you're doing
now are in the right place where a lot
of politicians their motivation can be
very self-serving at times this is not a
take or a conservative take this is
across the board right we need more
people in public office who have the the
desire to serve and help the greater
good to serve and help our country as
opposed to serving themselves perhaps no
greater example of this than the person
in in the Oval Office right now of
course within in President Trump who has
proven time and time again that he is
simply acting in his own self-interest
and we as a country need to get away
from that effective immediately
but certainly in November I I think
unfortunately politics attract certain
type of people some some of them are
awesome but like some of them just
really just love love to see themselves
on TV you'd love to see pictures of
themselves or posters like smeared up on
things I almost feel like we should take
people who would never run for office
and put them in charge what you would
never do actually like running around
and saying look at me look at me like we
should probably give you a lot of
responsibility because the the behavior
is necessary to run for office
successfully overlap only slightly with
behaviors you would want from like a
successful policy maker or or governor
or executive it's really strange JJ I
mean III said it to someone I was like
if you were a CEO with these behaviors
you'd be like the the shittiest CEO in
the world cuz your company is totally
going to behind you and all you're
doing is running around being like look
at me look at my vision like I used to I
used to operate you know a company and
like the important thing when you're
operating a company was the like
day-to-day the satisfaction of your
people like whether or not you were
actually providing whatever service
you're providing at like the highest
level yeah and most of those things had
nothing to do with it would be like you
know if an NBA player like just did
press all the time and stopped working
out I think something totally ridiculous
and so you're right that like
unfortunately the way our
running for office the mechanics like a
reward certain personality traits it
also frankly and I said this on the
trail before like I think it's tough
around women it's tough round
underrepresented minorities who often
don't have like a financial base or like
a bunch of people they can call and say
hey will you donate money to my campaign
so we're ruling out a lot of awesome
people from the get-go and one way I
think we could change that is if we just
like either financed campaigns publicly
or my proposal was we gave everyone a
hundred democracy dollars and then if
you don't have a lot of money like all
of your buddies would still have a good
Toddlers it doesn't matter if they're
rich buddies you know you could be like
anyone to be like hey you you know you
get a thousand people together that
would be like enough to get started but
yeah thank you for for saying that about
the way I came across on the trail like
you know I'm glad that was it was
apparent that you know I wasn't running
for you know some ego-driven reason yeah
[Music]
we're spending more time at home than
ever before and the question is how do
you keep yourself learning excited
interested creative skill shares a
fantastic resource it's an online
learning community with thousands of
classes for creative and curious people
who want to learn new skills hence skill
share I've actually been a fan of this
company for years and years in part
because I know the founder and he's a
great guy and he's a musician an artist
who just wanted people to learn stuff
and so one class that I I gotta say like
appeals to me a lot is filmmaking for
people at home right now it's being
taught by Penny Lane and they what they
say is like if you have found footage of
home videos you can actually make a
quality film out of it and that's
something that I feel like all of us can
relate to because I've got a lot of
weird crappy footage on my phone
typically of my kids and it is not
particularly shareable so if there is
some way I could make that stuff
actually legit Penny Lane and Skillshare
but it's not just that class it's
photography music illustration
freelancing just trying to build your
own business and entrepreneurship so
explore your creativity and get two free
months of premium membership at
Skillshare comm slash yang that's two
whole months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes for free join today
heading to Skillshare comm slash yang -
three months of unlimited access the
thousands of classes at Skillshare DICOM
slash yang
[Music]
I have a question for you and you you
may have talked about this on your
podcast before so I apologize but I'm
just curious what what was the biggest
thing you learned about politics in
general during the camp during your
campaign I was educated on the role of
the media and I talked to Tom Styer a
little bit earlier today and we were
like just like laughing about lessons
learned on the trail
Tom's another guy ran for president and
we were both talking about like that the
media would really put their thumb on
the scale in ways that like you found
very jarring in real time and I was sort
of naive I thought the job of the media
was to show up in report and so it's
like if I had a great event then you
would report that I had a great of it
you had to sort of catalog what was
going on but but there was very much
like this filtering and weighing that
the media was doing and they would do it
in ways big and small and I was
surprised by it repeatedly throughout
the campaign where like I was just like
you know like one example I use I'm not
sure I've spoken about this openly but
like I spoke at an event Iowa's one of
the first events I did it was in maybe
even 2018 and the headline speaker at
this event was Michael avenatti and this
was when he was talking about running
for president and so I gave and it was
like my big political speech debut now I
had like practiced at everything it was
like and then Michael avenatti spoke and
as far as the journalists in the room
were concerned it's like every I didn't
exist and it was like oh and I thought
objectively Michael gave a bad speech I
thought I was like well that was shitty
he just like read every word he went
five minutes over
I thought the applause was like polite
and then the journalists in attendance
were like Michael avatar do you think
and I was like what is going on like
that like that's that doesn't seem to me
to be like an objective depiction of
reality and so that was one of like the
first big
I got was that like the press had
certain narratives that they almost had
pre-loaded and then when the story came
like the story was almost pre-written
and and so like there was a period when
I was like trying to weigh my own
performance I was like oh if I just like
kicked more ass at that Iowa event then
they might have like written in like a
line or two or a paragraph about Andrew
yang but objectively you were great
objective but yeah it was like that this
is one of the issues you know with media
but it I think it's difficult for a
person but the personal side of
journalism it is difficult because we're
human beings to separate your own bias
and your own agenda and what you're
seeing because you're seeing it through
your lens that's difficult what when it
becomes really problematic is when the
corporate media has too much say in in
the lens that we're viewing and I think
you know what I'm what I mean by that
but when we're talking about
institutional bias and institutional
agenda that's what's telling the story
that's where we're seeing this this huge
divisive Mis I think across this country
yeah I agree and there's a growing
mistrust of various cable news channels
in corporate media as a result and that
mistrust is really destructive when
you're talking about for example of
pandemic and everyone's looking around
saying well what do I trust and you have
let's say certain news sources or
authorities saying wearing a mask is a
really good idea then some people
somehow that got politicized in some
circles you're like how the heck could
you politicize that one I literally
talked about this in my podcast I think
it was last week where it's like every
everything now and look we were told for
weeks not to wear a mask I'm sure we
what we all want to do over on that but
you know everything now every study out
coming out now will the way to mitigate
this the way to reduce this is to just
wear a mask and somehow that not wearing
a mask
has become at least on social media
you're owning the lives if you don't
wear a mask that's very dark it's I
don't get that I I don't I don't
understand that at all we're talking
about your own you know health the the
greater public's health maybe maybe a
relative's health yeah that's what we're
talking about we're not talking about
democratic or a Republican here yeah I
just tweeted the coronavirus doesn't
care if you're tired of the coronavirus
like you know it doesn't give a
about your politics it just wants to you
know get in there and and proliferate
and reproduce itself so one thing that's
going to make you I believe the yang
gangs favorite athlete is that you
actually were Pro universal basic income
before anyone had even heard of Andrew
yang and I'm actually like fascinated by
this because I'm really interested how
you came to this conclusion
independently before I even arrived on
the scene yeah so I I didn't come to the
conclusion independently
I certainly had some some some nudging
in the right direction so I I'd started
reading articles about you be I think
about 2017 and again you know as humans
we developed differently my sort of
social and political and awakening like
I'm in the middle of it right now
and I'm trying to figure it out because
you know you and I have talked about
this before we're I'm trying to figure
out sort of the second half of life and
what that means beyond just being a
basketball player and beyond just
truthfully being a dad like there's
there's something else out there
so I started hearing about you bi and 17
I read you know some of the results of
some of the studies done and then you
were on a podcast I think in the fall
sam harris sam harris his podcast yes
who's Sam is that's literally my
favorite podcast so you run on Sam
Harris's podcast and and and you were
obviously gearing up for this for this
run so that's what it really came into
sort of my consciousness and so I look
I've been a supporter of
you bi now for for almost two years you
know you and I have talked about how I
can get involved and some things that
you're doing it's something that I
support it's something that I inherently
believe in for a number of reasons I had
a question for you though about you bi
sure so this is a question that I have
has there ever been a study or a one of
these you know experiments that lasts
beyond a set number of years or is it
all been we're gonna do this for five
years we're gonna do this for ten years
whatever there's a term limit
essentially man I wish that we were
looking at five or ten years as the the
trial lengths mean most of the studies
that have been done have been for
shorter periods and than that maybe one
to two years would be customary so you'd
have to go further afield
there was a min come study in Canada
that extended for multiple years and it
was long enough so that people could
rely upon it and there you saw
incredibly positive effects around
people not just like being less stressed
out or mentally healthier but they
actually made different career decisions
based upon the fact that they could rely
upon this money they knew they had it
coming in for a number of years and so
you literally saw people start small
businesses and go back to school and do
all these things that you hope people
would do but there need to be more
trials that are longer in timeframe
because I think you know it's like you
get something you're like okay this is
great
but can you rely upon it long enough
where it actually starts making making
you like big different life decisions
right and and that's something we were
going to find out so we're doing a trial
you know that it's going to be for five
years and I think that might be one of
the longest trials going here in the
United States the other things that have
been out there unfortunately though I
will say in the developing world some of
these things are planning on extending
for a long period of time but they only
got started one or two years ago in some
of these settings like give directly
some of the work they're doing
internationally I believe is supposed to
be evergreen but it hasn't been around
long enough to be able to say what it
looks like five or ten long term
yeah that sort of brings me to - just
thought that I have about ubi in general
is you know is behavioral change has to
occur all right will occur if you know
something is gonna last longer than a
certain period of time I'll give you an
example so if I if I retire when I
retire I have a like a little brief at
the ripe old age of 46 after that after
the stroke eventually Abed that's you
know whenever I retire I have I have a
bridge program they call it the bridge
program where an annuity pays me a
certain amount of month until I hit age
50 and at that point I can I can take
out pension so at age 50 I can take out
my pension now at this point it is this
set up through the NBA or is this
something that is just through the NBA
and the NBPA
no this is through the NBA and BPA we we
basically 1% of all Bri goes to this
sort of program so they almost get 49 we
get 51 1% of that 51 goes towards health
benefits retired player care this bridge
program we eat an annuity based on your
years of service at page your certain
amount until age 50 50 you can take out
your pension what 50 I know exactly how
much money I'll get for my pension and I
know that it's gonna last the rest of it
I'll get paid that out the rest of my
life there is no there's no term limit
on that for most people when they retire
you know they're getting a pension or
they've got the 401k like these are
these are numbers that are sort of set
in stone that affects your behavior that
affects how you budget that's a bet
affects the risks you take when you're
talking about a one or two year period I
don't know that that's enough time to
directly affect behavioral change in
terms of risks and happiness to me
there's probably even more of a stress
factor they're like what am i what am I
gonna do with his extra money I've only
got only got 24 months to make this
happen
so I would be very interested to see you
know some if we could implement this on
a on a longer term basis I agree with
you we need
to make it so that people can actually
make different decisions and instead of
thinking like oh I will say happily like
I've personally given a thousand bucks a
month to several families and I'm happy
to say that it really does make them
feel like they have a lot of a lot more
freedom and liberty during that year and
it doesn't stress them out thinking like
please but I'm with you I think for most
people but for most people though like
like what you're talking about do I pay
my bills do I buy groceries do I pay for
my kids school do I get out of student
debt like we have there's so many
financial decisions that the average
person has to make and it's why this
miss money is so important that we get
it in people's hands I mean I it's a
benefit to the individual and it's a
benefit to society there's there's no
question in my mind yeah I agree
and most Americans now are waking up to
the fact that we can do this and we
should do this you know I just hope that
Congress follows the will of the people
I think the last poll I saw was
something like 72% of Americans agree we
should be getting cash relief during the
pandemic and you know it's funny to is
uh my campaign ended and then the energy
around me and universal basic income
just shot up because unfortunately and
we're in these circumstances
I mean we're ahead of your time you were
ahead of your time yeah five months
ahead of my time yeah or whatever that
were whatever it was
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by the
Jordan Harbinger show if you like
podcasts you should definitely check out
the Jordan Harbinger show it's designed
to make you understand the world better
and think more critically so you
remember that movie with Leonardo
DiCaprio catch me if you can remember
that conman Frank Abagnale so that's the
kind of person that Jordan has on to
talk about how the heck he became one of
the most prominent con men in the world
I guess if you can become a well-known
con man because you're supposed to be
secret and now advises the FBI how a
cinematographer discovered a lost city
in the jungle and was like a real-life
Indiana Jones it's that kind of stuff
so if that sounds appealing to you to
understand more about the world go to
Jordan Harbinger comm slash subscribe
and check it out this is one of Apple's
top 50 podcasts of 2018 hey maybe our
podcast will be on that list this year
we'll see my favorite episode was this
pseudo-science episode with this guy
named justin Ramsdale so I don't know
how many times you look and you see an
article there's like this study said
this this study says if you do this
you'll be better at XYZ and you never
know what's real science with
pseudoscience so there's a whole episode
of how to detect what's real what's fake
which I found really helpful
[Music]
[Applause]
so one thing I have to say like I don't
envy JJ is that there's been this multi
month period where you've been in
isolation and there's this restart
hanging off in the distance so for most
of us if we've done any kind of exercise
we like pat ourselves on the back and
we're like oh I didn't become a total
freaking yeah you know like Slugger
sedentary couch potato during this time
but for you guys oh my gosh you have to
like maintain yourself and like world
class condition in perpetuity just
because you don't know when the restart
is coming like that seems to me to be
the hardest thing in the world
particularly when you have like young
kids and the rest of you have to break
away like like what the heck did you do
to stay in shape because that seems
crazy I mean you must be like one of the
most self disciplined you know guys in
the world but like yeah what the heck
was your regimen ya know I'm a very much
a routine based person and so I made the
decision when everything got shut down I
left New Orleans I came up to New York
the first probably 10 to 14 days you
know I just kind of like sort of took
inventory of everything I was trying to
get as much information as possible
about timelines about what was going on
with the coronavirus about what was
going on with local and and you know
federal governments so a lot of that
first 10 to 14 days I was not focused on
basketball at all and I realized that
for me to stay sane during this period
of time that I had to get back in the
gym so after that sort of 14-day
quarantine I found access to a gym I
worked out every day for there you know
there for about two months and then I
came back to Brooklyn May 10th and I've
had access to a gym here so I've with
the exception of maybe the first two
weeks and then four or five other days
I've been in the gym every day I've
actually I may be one of the first like
14 pounds to be honest with you I I
weighed myself today I was 192 I left
New Orleans I was like 206 so I've lost
like 14 pounds now some of that of
course was post workout water weight but
I feel like I'm in great shape right now
I've done a ton of conditioning I need
to get back in New Orleans in Orlando
where I have access to a better wait
room than what I have access to right
now but all in all I feel like I'm in
I'm in good shape and I'll be prepared
to go you know I know there's been a
couple guys that have dropped out for
varying reasons and I think everybody
has their their motivations to play or
not to play and to me they're all very
valid because this is such a unique
situation you know that it's mean again
I think people are overlooking the human
aspect of a lot of this because what I
just said like staying in shape
throughout the quarantine hard
committing yourself mentally to go back
to play in a part of the country that
right now is seeing a spike in Kovach
cases for two months away from your
family I mean people don't realize what
a sacrifice that can be depending upon
what your situation is at home so it's a
lot you know to me I think like you just
said it would be very human and valid
for people to take different positions
on the restart and you couldn't blame
them like this is not a situation where
you'd be like oh what's with these guys
like you know like I want my sports
entertain me like you know like I think
there's like like a very legitimate
attack on both sides there's also the
feeling that some have that black lives
matter protests are front and center and
that you don't necessarily want want
anything to distract from that though
the flip side of that obviously is that
you know you can actually have a
platform to talk about social issues I
like the vantage points like I could see
people making whatever decisions right
for them on either side and being all
for it that the tough thing is that we
all know there's just a ton of money at
stake for both the players on the league
like if you don't finish the season I
think that that's like literally it's
almost like a billion-dollar hit across
players and owners the
teams and that's like a very very
powerful set of incentives to try and
figure out a way to finish the season
and you know a lot of players like you
might have very strong personal reasons
why you very much want to make sure you
get the season done and get the playoffs
in yeah in terms of me getting in the
playoffs I would say that's very far
down my list it's it's insignificant in
the grand scheme of things I I do
believe the financial reasons for
returning for either a player or the
league itself go beyond just the money
we stand to lose this year because I do
believe you know our CBA is sort of in
flux right now and and so if we decide
not to play or you know if if kovat
let's say wipes out Orlando and all of a
sudden we're in a lockdown and we can't
play like you know there's gonna be
financial repercussions in the next year
into the following year until things are
sort of back to normal in terms of fans
going to games we're looking at a hit
regardless you look my responsibility
just say this my responsibility always
is gonna be for my family and if I feel
like they are gonna be safe and and and
taken care of then I'm okay leaving them
do I want to leave them for two months
no of course not but my other
responsibilities is to the league into
the game it's been amazing to me and to
your point I get I totally understand
both perspectives of the motivation for
not playing versus playing with respect
to black lives matter I do believe there
is a huge opportunity for us to have a
platform but that platform goes beyond
just wearing a t-shirt or kneeling
during the anthem I believe it'll be the
first time we've had that many players
in one place the teams will be there the
league will be there we can have open
and direct conversations about coming up
with initiatives and and and actions
that will directly benefit black people
and black communities
I I believe that I believe that is the
opportunity in us playing and in us
going to Orlando beyond just having a
platform and a microphone in a camera
like I think we can get some things done
I think the league will negotiate that
on good faith I think our union is
motivated do that I know our players are
motivated to really put forth meaningful
change beyond just wearing a t-shirt and
and and and kneeling during the national
anthem like we need to move beyond that
there could be something very magical
and powerful about having that many
players in the same place along with
leadership and teams like you you can
imagine something very very significant
coming out of that kind of gathering not
just culturally but organizationally you
know resource wise but but the other the
flipside of that is is deciding not to
play and saying it's gonna be a
distraction from the black lives matter
movement totally get that two and agree
with that too
it's not wrong I don't think either side
either one of those perspectives is
wrong I think they're both right you've
seen WNBA players I think three or four
of them already
Natacha cloud Renee Montgomery Maya
Moore a couple years ago you've seen a
number of players come out and say I'm
gonna skip this season and focus on you
know the social justice movement that's
happening for black lives matter right
now and I applaud that I really do I
think I think it takes it a incredible
amount of courage to do that I I don't
know that it's right for an entire
league I don't know if it's wrong for an
entire league to sit out I don't know
the answer to that so it's it's a very
it's a very complicated situation for
sure well hats off to you for for
approaching it in a really thoughtful
way and as another family man it's true
when you know your family's gonna be all
right then you're capable of taking a
lot of things on you know what I mean
like what my family was like like I
could see that they were happy and
healthy and I was on the trail and I'd
be like it's all good like go do my
thing and certainly like you like you
know I feel very fortunate
side where where whenever anyone had
thanked me for running for office I
would say thank my wife because she's
the one who's doing more work if I take
it out of chin than relative to me so I
can relate very much to that sense of
security that you know enables you to go
out and play or fight or campaign so you
know I think you're approaching in a
great way I have a feeling that many of
the other players are approaching it
similarly I told my wife this on I think
it was either her birthday or Mother's
Day I put up a Instagram post and one of
the things I said to her both in her
card that day and on the Instagram post
was just how appreciative I am that she
allows me to pursue my obsessions like I
don't overlook that fact I don't
overlook the fact that I can be
obsessive about things and I pursue them
in my own way and she has always given
me the space to do that and the support
to do that and again it goes back to
your point about being out on the
campaign trail there's a part of you
there's a piece of your heart that is
just it's not there it's missing when
you're not with the people you love the
most but if you know that they're okay
and they know that you know that they're
supporting you then you can sort of go
forth with a great amount of of
confidence yeah I could never do the
things I I did not for Evelyn so you
know you say like you love you to your
spouse all the time I actually alternate
between saying I love you and I
appreciate you because there's like a
lot of gratitude the acknowledgement
that the acknowledgement it's what you
need yeah like I used to joke JJ like I
had to two priorities eliminate poverty
and stay married Oh long as I get those
two you know I've gotten the second one
done hopefully we can get the first one
done yes listen to the vast majority of
Americans who want to make it better
hey JJ such a pleasure talking to you
congratulations on really like an
incredible career what I know is going
to be in
credible second career I mean I said
this to you before but you're gonna
succeed in anything you put your mind to
man because like you you're you'd be
you're gonna end up being one of those
role models of NBA players that that do
something really really awesome as a
second act of your career and if there's
anything I can do I would be a resource
to help you in that regard please let me
know thank you Andrew and and I know I
told you this the other day when you
when you said that to me but it's
hearing those words out of your mouth
means a lot to me I also want to just
say I'm a very appreciative of the
opportunity to to come on your podcast
and as you have you've launched this
thing and huge honor to be on this pod
and and and and to be able to speak on
your platform so thank you man I
appreciate it
oh thank you man right back at you you
know you're the man yeah actually you're
it you're so you're actually if I put
this up on mine you're speaking on my
platform - that's true exactly I was
gonna say I got you it's my privilege to
show I'm on the JJ reddick podcast there
you go on the ringer network etc etc
[Music]